Peter King the mmq b.com Peter joins us
now Peter how are you Dan how's it going
today where are you I'm at LaGuardia oh
where are you flying to I'm going to
Indianapolis I'm doing some of the Colts
today so Frank Reich
interview is a is Andrew Luck going to
be available for you I actually
pre-recorded something with Andrew Luck
so but now I'm gonna do something with
Reich and with Valerie at a Colts event
in Indianapolis and I'm recording right
for my podcast this afternoon so we'll
be good what did you get from Andrew
Luck can you tease us with something I
mean you know he talked about how good
he's feeling and you know I think the
biggest thing about him right now is
that you you basically I think everybody
wants to know what his short and long
term future is I mean he he's only
played I think 20 or whatever it is 22
games in the last three years whatever
the number is nothing last year so I
mean I think I think he's confident that
he's going to be able to start throwing
the ball and throw throw the ball fine
once training camp starts but until he
does I think he knows that everybody's
gonna have a huge question about him did
Josh McDaniels have a huge question
about Andrew Luck that's a good question
Dan I think it was a combination of
factors with McDaniels probably the
uncertainty of I walked played into it
because anybody I mean obviously the
Colts are confident he's going to be
fine but you've got to wonder whether
he's going to be fine I think the larger
thing was I mean you know as I reported
a couple of weeks ago Dan he went into
his office at Gillette Stadium on
Tuesday morning after the Super Bowl and
when he left the house he was leaving
the house to go clean out his office and
to say goodbye to people
and that's when Robert Kraft and Bill
Belichick got involved with a
conversation that McDaniels wished he
had had with them around you know
December 7th instead of February 7th but
that decision obviously will continue to
reverberate and he's been Indianapolis
living in for me do you think they told
him privately that he is the coach in
Waiting but not to say something
publicly that I don't know it wouldn't
shock me if there's a nod and a wink
there Dan because I fully expected he
will be the successor to Bill Belichick
you don't have Bill Belichick saying to
you I'm gonna take you into my tap
decisions my trade decisions you know
from all indications this year you know
josh mcdaniels had zero to do with with
the Jimmy Garoppolo trade and knowing
McDaniels and knowing that he obviously
didn't want to lose Garoppolo I'm sure
he would have voted no on that but I
think that at least from the indications
from Belichick and and McDaniels is that
he's now going to be more significantly
involved in the decision-making process
so at Belichick can kind of lead him
into being the next coach I and I think
it's I don't want to say it's certain
but I think it's highly likely he'd be
the successor to Belichick why don't we
have the full story on Malcolm Butler
not playing in the Super Bowl yet
because you know I think the full story
might be that Belichick had really
soured on him as a player the big
question for Bellatrix that he is yet to
answer is why didn't you just deactivate
them if you weren't going to play him I
mean that's that's the biggest question
to me that we need to have answered if
you decided that you weren't playing
Butler and in a game where Johnson's
atomo CF
and others in that secondary really
really got gashed you know I mean I
don't understand why he was active and
why you would take one of your one of
your spots one of your 45 spots because
I don't really count Brian Hoyer Brady's
Brady's gonna play the whole game
why do you take 45 spots and give it to
a guy who apparently you're pretty sure
isn't going to play unless there is a
spate of injuries that's that's the
biggest question I'd have use Peter King
the mmq b.com joining us Dan Patrick
show Tom Curren floated this and it was
something that was sort of floated after
the Super Bowl with Rob Gronkowski I
don't know if it's a negotiating ploy
he's got two years left on his contract
but could you see Rob Gronkowski would
you be surprised if Gronk walked away
from the Patriots to pursue the
entertainment world surprised I guess
but not shocked I mean I said it after
the Super Bowl Dan he's played 115 games
he never stepped on the field again and
I was in the Hall of Fame six years from
now I don't know I'm not saying first
ballot but I mean I certainly would
support his entry in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame and so it could be that you
know remember when I did this with Brady
a year ago after the season he said you
know early in my career every day I was
this I was sore every day I was managing
pain and he said I just thought to
myself man is this the way my career's
gonna be and and so that's changed for
Brady and maybe Gronkowski feels the
same way it wouldn't it would surprise
me it wouldn't shock me because anytime
somebody quits a sport at the peak of
their skills it is surprising but you
know we don't know what the guy goes
through every week to play football the
whole quarterbacking situation here in
the offseason and even with the draft
coming up and teams that have money to
spend AJ McCarron's now unrestricted
free agent I mean there there's a lot of
moving parts here how do you see when it
all settles you know I
yes yesterday get it been added in my
column basically it it's so hard to tell
because if one domino falls wrong then
it affects where everybody goes like I
had Kirk Cousins going to Denver if Kirk
Cousins takes the max money and goes to
the Jets or Cleveland well that's going
to mess everything up if Hugh Jackson
wins AJ McCarron instead of another team
that really likes them Arizona well that
messes everything up too so I I mean
look I would might might guess right now
would be cousins to Denver McCarran to
Arizona a couple of quarterbacks to
Cleveland including one of the one in
the first four picks of the draft and
and then you know then what which one of
the losers and I mean which one of the
ones he doesn't who don't who won't get
cousins he is gonna spend huge for
somebody like Case Keenum that could
happen to in sort of foil Minnesota's
plot if they don't get cousins and
bringing Kenan back yeah there's a lot
of time with the combine and then the
draft and then what happens with some of
these other players there but could be
fascinating
Pete safe travels to Indianapolis always
great to catch up with you thank you all
the best dance thank you so much that's
Peter King the mmq b.com for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]